في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه أحزاب المعارضة على
إنهاء الصفقات الائتلافية ،
قد تشهد إسرائيل الأيام القليلة الأخيرة
لبنيامين نتنياهو كرئيس
للوزراء ،
وقد يكون بديله مساعده السابق
نفتالي بينيت
زعيم الحزب اليميني الصغير الذي
يُدعى يمينا الذي قراره بالانضمام إلى
زعيم الوسط  يار لابيد في محاولة
تشكيل حكومة ائتلافية جديدة
يمكن أن يغير مسار التاريخ الإسرائيلي
في خطاب ألقاه يوم الاثنين قال لابيد إنه في
غضون أسبوع يمكن أن
تدخل إسرائيل حقبة جديدة مع رئيس وزراء جديد
يعد بحكومة عاملة بعد
عامين من الخلل السياسي.
إذا تم تشكيل هذه الحكومة فإن
الكلمة الأساسية ستكون
مسؤولية تحمل المسؤولية لاستعادة الهدوء الداخلي
وعدم إلقاء اللوم على الآخرين وعدم البحث عن
أعداء وعدم وصم
أي شخص يفكر بشكل مختلف عنا
بالخائن الذي يجب قتله
حتى لو كان يشاريد 40 مقعدًا هذا هو.
الحكومة التي سأشكلها
يساراً يميناً وتتوسط حكومة وحدة
وطنية في السياسة الإسرائيلية سبعة أيام هي
أبدية  حيث يمكن أن يتغير الكثير
وقد يتسبب عدد قليل من المنشقين
في انهيار هذا الائتلاف
، وكما يرى العديد من المحللين السياسيين هنا أن
نتنياهو هو الناجي السياسي النهائي ، فإن
القليل منهم على استعداد لشطبهم
حتى الآن hadas gold cnn jerusalem.